all right yesterday Ohio Congressman Jim
Jordan announced that he was running for
Speaker of the House and earlier I sat
down with the congressman to ask why
he's running and what agenda he's gonna
push take a look
joining us now Ohio congressman Jim
Jordan who was announced he is running
to be the next Speaker of the House how
are you sir welcome
we're in studio appearance we're 101
days now outside of the midterm
elections I'm calling it the most
important midterm in our lifetime right
everyone impeach the president if they
win we got to win which point well if
the Democrats get in office they will go
after President Trump because they're
there they went so far left with this
socialist progressive Democrat you know
agenda they have so this is why it's so
critical and here's what's at stake
think about the last year-and-a-half
regulations reduce taxes have been
lowered unemployment its lowest in 20
years economy is just humming along
Gorsuch is on the court Cavanaugh is on
deck the embassies back in Jerusalem
we're out of the crazy Iran deal and the
hostages have come home from North Korea
and I'm forgetting a few things by
anyone's definition that is amazing year
and a half but what's amazing about that
list as well is a Congress only helped
with a little bit of that the regulation
the taxes Congress has got to do a
better job and that's why I want to be
the next Speaker of the House we got to
focus on doing what we told the American
people we were going to do delivering on
health care delivering on the border
security all those other let it happen
in the middle of the health care debate
we discovered that there are about a
hundred House Republicans and certainly
seven Senate house sorry Senate
Republicans that had voted to repeal
Obamacare in 2015
same bill same bill and then they
changed when it mattered six six
Republican senators voted against the
exact same legislation they'd supported
before after telling the Americans after
getting elected intend after getting
elected taking the Senate in 14 after
winning the White House in 16 on that
issue and then not to deliver on that we
haven't delivered on health care reform
repealing Obamacare haven't delivered on
welfare reform work requirements for
able-bodied people have heard delivered
on immigration policy and border
security wall and certainly haven't
delivered on holding and controlling
spending that's what we got to do
because that's what we told the American
people we were going to do if they gave
us the privilege to serve
okay put the President on his own as you
pointed out as a cop
and why is there this reluctance among
some Republicans is it the president is
not the conventional establishment
figure he's iconoclastic he's bold he
tweets he says you know calls that out
fake news what is it that some
Republicans don't like it's the town
it's Washington the swamp is the swamp
they don't like someone like Donald
Trump coming in there and changing the
swamp and changing the way that town
works there's just this reluctance to
ever change even though the American
people said in 2010 we're gonna put you
in charge of Congress to go change
things even though in 2014 they gave us
the Senate to say go change things and
even though in 2016 they gave us the
White House to go change things there's
still this reluctance and the president
feels that every stinking day because he
is he is bound and determined to do what
he told the American people he was going
to do what he ran on the mandate we got
from that election and the house needs
to do this thing we've done some good
things but not near enough the reform
that we need to do like the president
simply doing and that's varistor paul
ryan the house has been better than the
senate you get your house a lot better
let's go through this one so we have 14
states record low unemployment record
low unemployment for African Americans
Hispanic Americans and women in the
workplace and then take it from there
I mean we've had nothing but huge
massive economic great economic news one
after the other you've mentioned the
foreign policy successes and I'm
thinking there's a track record to run
on of course
let's go campaign on it and let's also
tell the American people you put us back
in power in the in the House of
Representatives we will do what we said
we will help president Trump accomplish
what you told us you wanted to
accomplish in 2016 what we all ran on
now if you become the speaker and look I
will support you for speaker because I
think the freedom caucus has been the
most committed to fighting to keep their
promises and literally the the single
biggest group fighting to defend the
things that are conservative in the
country and have helped the president
the most yeah we talked about when we
formed our group three years ago we
talked about the countless number of
Americans who feel like Washington has
forgotten them and left them behind we
want to go fight for those people do the
things we told him we were going to do I
say this all the time and I say
because I believe it we make the job of
being a member of Congress way too
complicated it's pretty simple what you
tell the people you're gonna do when
they gave the you the chance to go serve
them their family their business what
you tell them you're gonna do go do that
and be willing to stand up and have the
debate all too often we forfeit even
before the debate even happens before
the referee even blows the whistle we
just say we're gonna forfeit the match
we're going to forfeit the game
let's have that let's play the game
let's wrestle the match let's make it
happen
doing what we told him how will you be
different that's simple
here's a great example the omnibus
spending bill we were so poised to win
that debate and hold spending down on
non-defense spending do what need to be
done for our troops but hold it down on
everything else because Chuck Schumer
had shut down the memory shut the
government on Friday and over the
weekend the American people said you're
crazy so on Monday he says Shazam I'm
going to open the government back up
because he was losing in the political
in the public relations world so he
opens the government act up a few weeks
later we had a chance on that big
spending bill to treat our troops the
way they deserve to be treated for
defending our country and hold the line
on everything else and what do we do
what the swamp always does we said no we
won't even have the debate even though
we got a guy in the White House who was
great at debating great at taking the
message to the American people even
though we had all that we said let's
just do what we always do let's spend
more money on everything and the deficit
goes up the debt goes up and the band
plays on in the same old same old
presidents literally squeezed for those
if he wants the money for defense
because we literally have you say to him
a bad bill all right Jim Jordan we're
gonna watch this very closely do we know
when Ryan's leaving we do not you say
he's gonna stay so and I take him at his
word all right thanks for being with us
Matt thank you